hey leute und herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen kontakt und zwar sollte der
eigentlich gestern beim konter kommt ja
am sonntag kontakt sonntag ist das
einzig aber ich hatte gestern keine zeit
weil da noch die hero königswall war wo
ich dann auch anwesend sein musste wo
wir den neuen könig gewählt haben es
dauerte dann auch wieder eine stunde
weil wir dann aufgenommen haben dann
aber noch gequatscht und blablabla und
dann war es halt schon irgendwie 890
mich dass er noch bearbeitet und
gerendert und hochgeladen hätte wäre das
video vielleicht um halb zwölf online
gekommen das wollte ich euch jetzt auch
nicht antun und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht hat den kontakt wieder am montag
hoch allerdings werde ich euch
versprechen wenn der kontakt nächsten
sonntag nicht pünktlich kommt irgendwie
nachmittags am sonntag dann werde ich
nackt eine rutsche runter rutschen und
das film und jetzt habe ich das gesagt
deswegen werde ich den pünktlich bringen
also na ja jetzt geht man richtig los
mit dem video fasste ziert die ans netz
schon vollständig reingucken
und zwar habe ich ja letztes mal gefragt
bzw in dem video von gestern auf dem
kontakt entweder eure kommentare
beantwortet haben sehen wollt oder ob
wir meinen tag in hamburg zusammen
gefasst haben wollten meine tage in
hamburg mehr oder weniger obwohl ich
noch einen tag zusammen gefasst habe
allerdings kamen relativ einstimmig bei
raus dass sich hamburg zusammenfassen
soll das auch mein interesse ist weil
ich sonst sagen sonst aufgenommen hätte
die die ich da so aufgenommen habe und
ich krieg hat man keine luft mehr
peter u naja jedenfalls war ich halt vom
zweiten bis vierten in hamburg ich wurde
auch ca 10 15 mal erkannt was mich sehr
gewundert hat weil ich eigentlich
gedacht hätte so
da kenne ich bestimmt keiner so hamburg
und so da weil sie nicht da sind auch
nicht so viele leute jetzt eigentlich so
rumgelaufen wo ich so gedacht habe dass
meine videos schauen also wir haben echt
so leute angesprochen so ein 17-jähriger
weil er beide war richtig richtig cool
drauf der stand der mich im klosterladen
erkannt und es war richtig richtig
witzig die ganze zeit und ich habe noch
ein paar erkannt vor irgendeinem anderen
laden dann einfach ankommen quote machen
ich sagen ich bin nicht so gesagt kraft
gehörte war das war ganz schön dich also
ist irgendwie witzig wenn man sein kann
irgendwie weil sie nicht das gibt einem
immer sie diese motivation das ganze so
weiter zu machen das ist irgendwie
lustig ich musste die ganze zeit grinsen
das ist doch einfach nur irre wenn man
das erkannt wird das ist einfach man
fühlt sich dann irgendwie ich fühle mich
nicht wie sonst da war wenn man erkannt
wird fühlt man sich dann irgendwie so so
ich weiß nicht man fühlt sich irgendwie
so komisch man fühlt sich irgendwie so
peinlich weil die anderen vielleicht zu
gucken ist der vielleicht etwas berühmt
ist aber in wirklichkeit ist man also
pseudo berühmt also nur so in der in der
branche dass nur die leute aus der
branchenkenner sind also die leute die
displays gucken aber es auch egal
jedenfalls habe ich ein paar sachen
aufgenommen und zwar war ich am dritten
haben mich zwei kumpels von mir besucht
in hamburg die auch in der nähe gewohnt
haben lassen zwillinge die heißen finden
und jan und dann haben wir ein paar
sachen aufgenommen am tag ich weiß die
kameraperspektiven und die
kameraeinstellungen und ansichten und
kamera orte wo das gefilmt haben sie
alle sehr sehr schlecht gewählt und man
sieht teilweise echt mal in sandwich
oder man nur meine füße oder so aber es
ist halt einfach so weil ich habe mich
noch nie so in der öffentlichkeit so
gefilmt
somit zum mit dem iphone dann einfach so
gefüllt und so hey leute bleiben haben
aber so im c & a drin einfach weiß nicht
dass ich bin nicht so der typ ich finde
es total das ist nein ist das peinlich
jedenfalls wollte ich so ein bisschen
mein tag zusammenfasst ich hoffe mir das
gelungen gesungen luca sprachfehler dies
das jedenfalls werde ich euch jetzt
hintereinander die szenen einblenden und
werd immer so zwischendurch dann so ein
bisschen was dazu sagen und zwar war die
erste szene die wir aufgenommen haben
das ist mir ganz spontan eingefallen
eigentlich wollte ich in hamburg einfach
so drehen wie ich vor der alster sitze
und dann einfach nur so ein bisschen
quatschen so über das alte jahr und so
was alles allerdings war ich so scheiß
wetter das überall
überall lag matsch und regen und ein
bisschen schnee
na ja halb schnee das eigentlich auch
schon nur regen oder
wie koks oder mail oder so deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht ich fast mein tag so ein
bisschen zusammen und film da so ein
bisschen was mir allerdings auch nicht
so gut gelungen ist ich hoffe euch
gefällt trotzdem wenn es euch gefällt
der für eine bewertung lassen
und wie gesagt mir kommentare schreiben
die ihr sohn an mich stellen wollte und
dann will ich sagen
die erste szene also eine ganz spontane
idee dieses follow me round zu machen
das war im c&a im hafen vitte ließ es
glaube ich nämlich hafenviertel dass es
irgendwie weiß nicht da wo etwa kombi
ist da glaube ich irgendwie da im alter
hausmeisterhaus bei c&a haben wir
angefangen das aufzunehmen und das zeige
ich euch jetzt erst mal ganz kurz stehen
vor den hosen in hamburg immer noch
richtig das übrigens 500 zwillingsbruder
und der ist gerade kleidung christian
und schreib mal in die kommentare 1 2
oder 3 welche rosa 123
kameraführung läuft bei mir gucke ich
nicht so ein alter der laden die boxen
ja ich war sind jetzt geht's weiter
informieren und in hamburg weil jetzt
gleich geht es war schon das fressen
richtig fit so da habt ihr jetzt drei
hosen gesehen und zwar in zwei oder drei
ich glaube ein paar leute haben sogar
schon die kommentare geschrieben
letztendlich hab ich mir gar keine hose
gekauft
jedenfalls sind wieder nach halt was
essen gegangen und zwar bei subway das
ist der einzige fast food laden zudem
ich zurzeit noch hingehen mac ist und
burger king und casey das ist alles so
eine verpackte scheiße geht noch aber
der rest ist einfacher weiß nicht ich
krieg' ich kann keinen fast für messen
irgendwie und ich weiß auch in einer
gewissen form fast wird allerdings will
ich mir besser bei wenigstens ein dass
es noch gesund ist obwohl die ganzen
früchte acht früchte dieses ganze gemüse
oder auch nur das gemüse tomaten und
gurken ist gemüse das ist obst gemüse
und obst gemüse das gemüse
ich glaube das gemüse das ist halt auch
alles eingelegt da und das ist auch
nicht so gesund wie man sich das
einbilden aber ich finde es richtig gut
und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt herr luca
was ist immer besser bestellt euch
einfach mal ein halbes boutiquen
teriyaki mit scheiben käse getoastet
selbstverständlich und dann scheiß aus
oliven und rapace und gewürzgurken das
einzige was ihr drauf sind tomaten
gurken und feldsalat mehr nicht und als
hose als sauce müsst der handymast hut
nehmen und als brot hand und das nimmt
ihr einfach und ihr werdet im siebten
himmel sein ihr werdet das ist einfach
nur gerne das hab ich grad gegessen
von michael j
gerade schön und jetzt fragt ihr euch
bei mir ist das nicht reden
mp kamera ist ein chip integriert
tomaten und oliven und animas kampagne
natürlich das ganz ohne ironie
sympathisch so die nächste sehen dass
das wo man endlich mal ein bisschen mehr
sieht und zwar sind wir unter der europa
passage hergelaufen durch sonnen gang
weil wir ihnen die ganze zeit im
volksbad gesucht haben weil ich bin bei
der volksbank runde und nicht bei der
sparkasse und ich habe danach bekommt
wie meiner volksbank und halt nicht bei
der sparkasse deswegen überall in
hamburg sind sparkasse und es gibt ihn
wieder eine volksbank keine ahnung also
so kam es uns vor wir mussten erstmal
kilometer laufen bis wir da waren und
dann hat es noch geregnet dann haben wir
halt noch andere freunde getroffen und
dann waren wir letztendlich eine stunde
unterwegs sind auf dem weg zur volksbank
und haben dann geld abgehoben dann habe
ich gesehen dass ich nur noch 15 euro
auf dem konto hatte haye
naja jedenfalls sind wir dann halt unter
dieser europa passage hergelaufen und
was da so passiert ist beziehungsweise
was da so war das eigentlich nix ich hab
das nur kurz zusammengefasst was war und
was wir dann gemacht haben egal ihr seht
jetzt laufen hier gerade um weiterhin
die tramps und bewusst die europa
passage europa passage links und scheiß
gras eben wo die europa passage und ich
habe mir so eingebildet dass hamburg
richtig scheiße selber hamburg sei ihm
jedoch ganz geil ich kann halt nur so
diese komische daten zwillinge guckt
mich mal zwillinge davon ist davon ist
die alster ganz hinten könnte schlechte
karten sehen aber sonst noch ein
bisschen weiter rum da gehen wir zeigen
euch gleich europa wir zeigen euch
gleich im all arbeiten sollten
danach saßen wir bei görtz hieß der
laden glaube ich im schuhladen weil film
brauchte noch irgendwie schuhe und hat
dann sich auch schuhe gekauft glaube ich
und ich saß da halt einfach nur rum und
allgemein die kameras perspektive es
blöd gewählt weil wir so von unten
gefilmt man das sieht mega creepy aus
aber das werdet ihr gleich am ende auch
noch einmal feststellen wenn ich mich
einfach so filme wie ich in einem
anderen laden sitzt es sieht mega krise
nicht von unten filme aber ihr seht das
jetzt
wo sitzen
ich wollte gerade erkannt von paul also
ein cooler cola bruder du bist richtig
also ich kann jetzt nicht so viele leute
einfach etwas ganz offen ich verstehen
könnt ich hoffe doch jetzt einfach mal
es kam es bisher glaubte man ja ich war
ja kurz ich krieg dich wieder freundlich
also was ist jetzt ein video trinken
gehen werde ich euch noch mal mit von
meinem tag im hotel schildern ist die
forscher verschiedene also bester tag in
hamburg überhaupt so kooperativ so
danach sind wir in einen laden gegangen
wo die hemden hatten und da haben wir
waren halt vorher schon in dem laden wo
wir uns ein weißes hemd jeder gekauft
aber ich habe ihn wie kein weißes hemd
ich weiß nicht warum jeder hat ein
weißes hemd ich habe keins ich brauche
jetzt bei endlich 1 und hab mir dann in
einem anderen laden da im alsterhaus hab
ich mir dann weißes hemd gekauft so
schön und gut ich gehe in den anderen
laden da irgendwie weiß nicht wo bei der
ich glaube das war enden sie ist der
alle hamburger kennen das glaube ich
enden das ist da irgendwie auf dem weg
zum hauptbahnhof und da habe ich dann
das gleiche weiße hemd gesehen runter
gesetzt und viel geheiratet
oder ich weiß grundgesetz war auf jeden
fall viel geiler vorhanden weil es zu
besserer stoffe und alles und dann habe
ich mir gedacht okay das haus jetzt um
ich laufe wieder in den anderen laden
gibt dass der händler zurück mit mühe
und not und mühelos für wieder in den
anderen laden kaufen das andere eben
doch wieder in die innenstadt und das
waren solche kag entfernungen und laden
die länder sind lockern kilometer
auseinander gewesen
also das war echt so ein bisschen
ärgerlich dass ich dann immer von anna b
kaufen laufen musste und ein problem bei
mir ist auch einfach wenn ich etwas sehe
dann kaufe ich dass ich die ich legte
ich bin viel zu umständlich dafür um
einfach zu sagen
legen sie das bitte zurück ich guck mal
anderen leben da laufe ich andere leben
durch blablabla hole mir dann das andere
vielleicht doch nichts besseres gefunden
habe
ich kaufe einfach direkt weil ich weiß
nicht ich habe da keinen das ist nein
ich habe keine motivation dazu einfach
jemals zurück zu legen und dann an
andere leben zu gehen irgendwie muss das
irgendwie immer direkt kaufen weil sonst
ist das auch endlich kann
jedenfalls wie ich dann da in dem laden
setzte wo ich das bessere hemd entdeckt
habe seht ihr in dem video und zwar film
ich dann meine schuhe ja deine freunde
wieder einmal sitzen wir in einem laden
ein richtig richtig schöne stuhl wenig
munition kaufen möchte ich noch mal
probieren wir gehen jetzt noch komplett
hamburg danach habe ich mir bei migräne
currywurst geholt und die ist echt mega
geil also müll grill ist glaube ich
mehrmals waren in hamburg ich habe mir
die currywurst dabei dem apple store da
geholt dabei wo es in untergrund geht da
ist sein mögen currywurst land haben die
besten currywürste die ich je gegessen
habe die kosten drei euro was sodann
relativ annehmbarer preis ist ihm egal
fix fertig und ist so geil also mögen
currywurst best hier seht ihr wie ich
die gegessen habe und wie ich mich
orientierungslos in hamburg befindet
läuft weiter durch hamburg computer eine
leckere currywurst gekauft bei möglich
die technisch gut die kann ich nur
weiterempfehlen
wir haben hier rechts
ricoh ist es und wir recht gegen die
championne 2
danach sind wir mit dem taxi erstmal
nach hause gefahren das hat halt
komplett geregnet deswegen damals ein
taxi genommen auch weil mein hotel circa
zwei kilometer von der innenstadt
entfernt war habe ich mir dann halten
taxi genommen beziehungsweise wir uns
und sind dann erstmals hotel gefahren
und das seht ihr jetzt gerade halt
einfach so zusammengefasst ihr seht mich
gerade gar nicht das habe ich ganz so
spontan entschieden das ist jetzt schon
sieht und das war auch ganz langweilig
also das ist einfach nur warte im stall
raster danach waren wir in dem
restaurant la vela etwas essen und zwar
ist das so ein relativ kleines
restaurant also ich mit meiner familie
war
und da habe ich euch davor noch mal kurz
den hafen zusammengefasst man hört mich
immens schlecht weil da echt war es war
sturm das war heftig willst es hat so
geregnet
überall kam wasser und wie das la villa
seit direkt an der elbe
und da kam wellen hoch und alles in das
war mega krass aber was ich in dem video
gleich doch sagen werde ist ich werde
euch einen großen frachter zeigen der
war mega heftig lang das sieht man nicht
weil man hier nur so von hinten sieht
von von schräg von hinten und ich zeige
euch noch eine yacht von abramowitsch
und zwar hat der irgendwie ne 1000
milliarden euro ich achte gebot und dies
locker weiß nicht die über locker sowie
eine kirche develop a 40 50 meter hoch
und die stadt erhalte im hafen tiefer
komplett abgedeckt mit seinem gerüst ich
weiß nicht ob es ein sichtschutz war für
die öffentlichkeit oder ob es einfach
nur daran lag dass die arbeiter auch bei
schlechten wetterverhältnissen arbeiten
können allerdings ihr seht ihr jetzt im
video zusammengefasst nur der ton ist
halt sehr schlecht
da liegt ein gewisser millionen
dann hat uns meine mutter mitgenommen
planetarium und zwar ist das eben
besonders eine große kuppel und da
werden immer da werden dann so sachen
drauf projiziert also die haben richtig
richtig viele lasertechnik technik
sachen und lichter und so was alles und
man sitzt quasi da drin
in seiner kuppel ich blende euch das
jetzt mal ganz kurz ein und zwar guckt
man dann halt quasi so nach oben und als
auch sein viertes lederkugel dinge in
der mitte und das projiziert dann so
ganz viele sachen oben drauf da keine
filme gezeigt werden das ist in 3d alles
und da war zurzeit eine vorstellung von
pink floyd
das ist eine band und wir hören die
eigentlich alle gar nicht aber zwar hält
megageil und es war einfach so laut und
das war einfach ein mann fühlte sich wie
mittendrin und dann wenn zum beispiel
eine animation war unterläuft ein typ
gerade auf einen zu man denkt echt so
hilfe der red mich gleich um weil man
von überall kamen laut stärken geräusche
als man dachte man sei quasi mittendrin
dabei und das war halt einfach mega
trucks und mega geil einfach obwohl ich
die musik von pink floyd eigentlich
überhaupt nicht mag bzw nicht was
hässlich mag ich es halt einfach nicht
ruhm eine kamera geht einfach auswahl
der akku voll ist geil ja ich hab's
neuer co-trainer sicher pink floyd nicht
so regelmäßig und mag das eigentlich
auch nicht so aber man fühlte sich
irgendwie so als wenn man auf drogen
also ich war noch nie auf einer droge
die ihr vieh weise nicht sogar
hervorruft also für allgemeiner nicht
auf drogen aber ich glaube so ist und
wenn man es im film auch immer sieht
dann wäre es glaube ich genauso sein
weil da sind überall haben und spiral
effekte und alles und das dreht sich
alles und man also es war auch so
teilweise dass man in einem
sternenhimmel war das konnte ich aber
nicht film mal das war total dunkel
einfach nur und wenn man flog an der
erde vorbei man hat sich wirklich so
gefühlt weil man quasi in diese kuppel
rain man hat sich so geführt hat wird
man sich wirklich drehen und das war so
krass mir wurde ein bisschen schlecht
das war mega heftig ein
oder nach wann der nächste tag und zwar
habe ich eigentlich gesagt dass ich den
tag noch einmal im hotel zusammen fassen
wollte also habe ich vorhin schon
irgendwann so eine aufnahme gesagt aber
habe ich nicht mehr geschafft ich war
müde ich habe mich ins bett gelegt und
indirekt architekt jedenfalls am
nächsten tag bin ich dann einfach so
nach oben gewatschelt meine schwester
musste noch ein paar sachen umtauschen
weil die irgendwie weise nicht die hat
sich irgendwie was falsches gekauft oder
irgendwie sowas natürlich immer in der
die laufen dann einfach mit darum und
lasst uns mit stören und dann sind wir
halt dann irgendwann dazu angekommen
dass wir dann noch mal in der innenstadt
halbwaren und da war dann eine
tanzvorstellung von so breakdancen
allerdings naja guckt euch mal für die
aufnahme an
und zwar direkt als ich angekommen bin
dachte ich so wie jetzt geht's los die
fangen jetzt grade an zu tanzen auf
einmal der typ wir wollen jetzt wo
anfangen kommt jetzt mal ja und dann
sagt meine mutter ja wir müssen jetzt
auch noch ausfahrt blabla wollte er zu
gucken zu applaudieren
ja und dann sind wir nach hause gefahren
ich durfte halt fahren weil ich ja
dieses begleitete fahren nur 18 mache
also dieses ich bin jetzt noch 17 6
wochen haben wir hier noch 17 oder
sieben wochen zu egal jedenfalls bin ich
dann halt gefahren und ich war schon ein
bisschen müde auf der fahrt und fahrten
nie wenn ihr ein bisschen müde seid ich
fast einen unfall gebaut das war so
krass ich fuhr auf der linken spur auf
die oft mit getürkten da hätte ich vor
auf der linken spur auf der autobahn und
es kam auf einmal sein audi r8 oder so
von hinten an der kam richtig angezeigt
locker mit 240 oder so ich bin schon 190
gefahren oder oder 180 und wir haben
einfach an und ich denken zu ok gut wenn
man auf der linken spur und einer will
dann trotzdem überholen und drängelt ein
bisschen fährt man natürlich rechts
rüber auf die mittlere oder auf die
rechte spur
damit man den drängler überholen lassen
kann ich blinker rechts will nach rechts
rüber fahren auf einmal fährt dieser
audi rechts auf die mittlere spur und
überholt mich von rechts alter also von
rechts überholen auf der autobahn ist
absolutes no go das darf man nicht da
sondern die wir hinter einen bleiben und
so ein bisschen vielleicht lichthupe
machen wenn man überholen will oder so
aber auf jeden fall nicht rechts
überholen weil als ich gesehen habe und
ich grad rechts rüber fahren wollte und
er war nicht mal eine sekunde hinter mir
jetzt einfach quasi so gefahren und
direkt land vorbei das war richtig crazy
wenn ich dann einfach nicht noch mal im
rückspiegel geguckt hat und wenn mein
vater nicht gesagt hätte halt stopp der
linken spur
dann wäre ich von dem rhein gerastet und
ich will gar nicht wissen was dann
passiert wäre das war echt dann war mein
puls auf 180 das war
boah krass ja da war ich halt am abend
wieder zu hause am sonntag und dann
waren wir halt noch auf einer party und
dann war noch die hypo königswall
deswegen habe ich wirklich nicht mehr
hinbekommen die ganzen sachen jetzt hier
aufzunehmen ich war nicht am sonntag
wieder am samstag wieder zu hause und am
sonntag war die königsblauen bleibt da
ist jetzt auch mit ganz egal jedenfalls
habe ich gestern nicht mehr hingekriegt
deswegen kommt der kontakt heute der
nächste konter kommt wirklich wieder an
hoffentlich dass ich hoffe dass ich es
schaffen werde jetzt muss ich das ganze
auch sehr schnell noch bearbeiten und
dann auch hochladen damit ist jetzt auch
noch passen habt und sonst würde ich
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat was eine
bewertung da und ich wünsche euch viel
spaß wieder in der schule nächste woche
ich habe erst am mittwoch wieder schulen
ändern wir hier
und dann will ich sagen ich hoffe euch
hat ein bisschen gefallen das war mein
erstes voll und deswegen was ein
bisschen 08 15
wollt ihr noch mehr schreibt seine
kommentare und